bonsoir
l'influence
pour la plupart des gens quand nous
parlons d'influence on en a souvent une
image négative
ne te laisse pas influencer par ses
bêtises tu as de mauvaises
fréquentations qui t'influencent mais
rarement j'ai entendu dire au contraire
laisse-toi influencer par cette personne
ça arrive mais très rarement
alors que nous vivons dans une époque où
le mot influenceur est presque devenu un
métier on devrait se poser la question
pour qui pourquoi souvent dans un but
financier mais est-ce une fatalité ce
soir je vais essayer de vous donner mon
point de vue sur cette question
donc je me présente je m'appelle Jérémy
j'ai un trentaine et je suis l'Alsace
depuis plus de 12 ans je me bats pour la
solidarité l'espoir face à la maladie
mon seul but dans ce processus est
d'essayer d'influencer les gens qui me
suivent à croire en eux à ne pas laisser
la maladie guider leur vie et ne pas
baisser les bras j'appellerai ici
l'influence par source d'inspiration
effectivement je me bats moi-même depuis
plus de 12 ans contre plusieurs maladies
dont une maladie des poumons qui m'a
particulièrement affecté elle m'a mené
d'hospitalisation en hospitalisation et
de traitement en traitement
elle aurait pu elle m'influencer de
façon négatif
me laisser aller ou guider ma vie mais
je ne l'ai pas laissé faire même si je
cache pas que bien souvent rentrant à la
maison et que je ferme la porte que je
regarde à gauche ou à droite et que
personne ne me voit je verse mes petites
larmes de désespoir et mes
questionnements pour ne pas déranger les
gens dans leur quotidien
à 22 ans
plus moyen de monter deux étages sans
être essoufflés à 22 ans alors qu'à ce
moment-là j'aurais dû profiter comme
tous les potes aller en boîte de nuit
faire un foot aller boire une bière mais
la maladie me l'a empêché
en l'espace
de quelques mois j'ai pris 32 kg frelon
presque le quintal je vous laisse
imaginer je vous laisse même calculer
à cet instant le cerveau se met en état
de choc et se pose des questions
que je fais pour mériter ça
à quoi je sers vous imaginez vous posez
la question à 22 ans à quoi je sers
en 2019
près de 10 ans d'une action plus tard
les médecins me conseillent vivement de
me remettre au sport
il a bien dit sport lui le médecin qui
me suit depuis plusieurs années
aurait-il oublié que la maladie
ronge mes muscles mes poumons et mes
yeux mais il a du sport soit
mais maladies
mon parcours ont puisé chez moi une
force l'envie de me battre il forte
motivation
mais quelle motivation allège bien
trouver pour me remettre au sport
alors je me suis dit pourquoi
j'utiliserai pas le sport cette
nécessité indispensable et vitale à ma
santé physique et mentale pour me lancer
un défi face à la maladie
et en même temps passé un message
d'espoir aux gens qui souffrent comme
moi
après quelques semaines de réflexion
j'ai eu l'idée d'un défi mais avant de
vous raconter je vais vous dévoiler un
peu les réactions que j'ai eu autour de
moi
tu es fou
quelle idée à la con
tu ne vas jamais y arriver tu ne vas
jamais y arriver vous pouvez imaginer
comment j'étais heureux d'un seul
soutien de la part de mes proches
alors arrive le moment où je vais aller
annoncer au médecin sur ses conseils que
j'avais me remettre doucement au sport
et par la même occasion me lancer un
défi face à la maladie
plus la discussion avançait
plus il devenait livide
alors je me suis demandé si ça peut être
lui mon patient et moi le médecin
et
je suis rentré donc chez moi
avec encore plus d'envie de réussir car
à ce moment-là j'avais compris que
c'était bien plus qu'un simple défi vu
l'état de mon corps et de mes poumons
me voilà lancés dans l'organisation de
mon défi que je vous dévoile à présent
mon action était de marcher Colmar à
Paris 500 km en moins de 12 jours 9
heures de marche 40 km et je vous passe
le nombre de tendinites
le soir je rentre à la maison après ce
rendez-vous avec le médecin
et je décide de faire une petite vidéo
sur Facebook pour annoncer aux gens mon
idée de défi
de solidarité et d'espoir et à ma grande
surprise en quelques heures j'ai eu
énormément de soutien du message
d'encouragement de félicitations et
énormément de messages de gens
hospitalisés qui m'écrivaient en me
disant vas-y bats-toi on est avec toi
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer ça m'a tout
de suite motivé à continuer
ni une ni deux je prends la direction de
la salle de sport c'était très compliqué
je cherche les partenaires qui
m'aideront à financer cette marche
et je publie quotidiennement encore sur
Facebook et Instagram mon quotidien de
malade mes opérations les traitements
les rendez-vous avec les médecins j'ai
ouvert vraiment ma vie à tous les
abonnés et tout doucement les abonnés
augmentaient c'est ce qui m'a confirmé
que j'étais sur la bonne voie pour
réussir ses défis et à citer les gens à
ne jamais baisser les bras
alors arrive les premières Télévisions
les premières radios les premiers
articles de presse
énormément de messages de soutien de la
part des différentes personnalités c'est
ce qui a donné encore plus de poids à
mon action et je me suis dit à cet
instant pourquoi j'allais pas trouver un
parrain pour mon action et qu'elle
parrain moi encore aujourd'hui j'en
reviens pas c'était le DJ Bob Sinclar le
DJ mondialement connu qui est à mes
côtés d'ailleurs il était là au départ
de ma marche à Colmar puis à l'arrivée à
Paris et tout au long de ma mâche il m'a
envoyé des petits messages de soutien
l'encouragement et de félicitations car
lui aussi était un grand sportif
finalement au départ de ma marche
c'était plus de 51 artistes qui se
tenaient à mes côtés ça allait de baisse
dit tôt à Richard Berry à Laurent
Deutsch à Claudio Capéo et j'en passe
ils étaient à mes côtés car ils ont cru
à la nature de mon combat et la force
qui me fallait pour lutter contre toutes
ces maladies
alors
tout au long de ma marche je traversais
la France l'est en ouest soutenu par
plus de 200 000 personnes sur les
réseaux sociaux
et l'influence que j'ai eu à ce moment
là était positive et magique
beaucoup de gens m'écrivaient pour me
raconter leur vie leur souci quotidien
énormément de gens malades m'écrivaient
tout au long de ma marche pour me dire
que eux aussi ils allaient continuer le
combat face à leur propre maladie et
peut-être même se remettre au sport
finalement mon message
était bien passé et j'en étais fier
mais je n'oublie pas non plus que si
j'ai réussi ce défi c'est grâce au
soutien de toute mon équipe car ils ont
eu une influence positive sur moi
marcher sous la pluie
sous la grêle sous l'envoi souvent
l'envie d'arrêter par la douleur mais
était là et mon motivé à avancer
bien que j'ai eu la chance d'être
médaillée de la ville de Paris
du département du Haut-Rhin d'être élu
alsacien de l'année 2019
d'être reçu par le président François
Hollande et le prince Albert de Monaco
ma pubienne Ferté sans conteste toutes
ces messages d'amour et de positif
positivité que j'ai pu recevoir
ça a été très important
alors
quelques mois il m'a fallu
pour me remettre de cette marche pour
récupérer
et j'ai continué à garder un lien
intense que j'avais tissé avec mes
abonnés
et du coup c'est ce qui m'a motivé à
faire un deuxième défi
allez c'est reparti cette fois-ci le
défi était de marcher 24 heures non-stop
pour atteindre 100 km autour d'un stade
de foot
ce qui représente à peu près plus de 200
tours de terrain
cette fois-ci mon défi mon défi était
ouvert à tous
malade ou non
adulte ou enfant alors c'est plus de
1000 personnes qui se sont relayées à
mes côtés pour m'accompagner et essayer
de réussir ce défi qu'ils aient chaussé
leur basket pour faire quelques tours de
piste
quelque part où nous encourager autour
du stade ils étaient là avec moi pour
m'encourager et aussi ont une influence
positive sur moi
les défis que j'ai pu relever
ont inspiré de nombreuses personnes dans
leur défi de vie
et de maladies c'est en partie
l'influence positive que j'ai eu sur eux
qui ont fait qu'ils n'ont pas lâché le
combat face à la maladie
donc je pense que l'influence négative
telle qu'on peut la percevoir n'est pas
une fatalité
car même si souvent on a l'impression de
la subir
en réalité on a le choix ou non de la
suivre
car même à l'air des réseaux sociaux
nous restons responsables du clic que
nous portons à une page
à une publication
à une personne et encore plus importante
au message qu'elle veut donner
notre parcours
nos regrets
nos remords
nos joies nos défaites
font ce que nous sommes
et influence notre vie
et je dis souvent j'ai envie de donner
mes yeux de malade aux gens en bonne
santé
pour qu'il puisse voir un peu le monde
autrement
puisse relativiser un peu leur vie
aider un peu plus les autres et les
comprendre donc peut-être que tous
ensemble on pourrait avoir une influence
positive sur les autres
et pour moi le plus important c'est
essayer de vous faire comprendre qu'il
faut vivre aujourd'hui plutôt que demain
merci
c'est super il est super